das hier wahrscheinlich das schwierigste
video was ich jemals für youtube
aufgenommen habe hallo leute hier wieder
einmal wanne und ich habe euch was zu
sagen
die einzelnen interessierte vielleicht
und den anderen ist auch scheißegal ich
habe eine neue modelle
aber das ist noch nicht lange schon
bewohner derzeit keine videos kam obwohl
ich davor so regelmäßig war also schwer
auf das richtige zu sagen denn jeder hat
seine eigene vorstellung davon wie man
mit persönlichen dingen umgehen und
damit auch wirklich jeder zu lieben und
ich kann abonnenten verliere
seht ihr den arten und sagen das ist
wieder single worten ach ja ich bin
wieder single
ihr könnt ihr auf hin zu franz man
freundet nur ich entscheide was mit euch
teile und was nicht emotional
eigentlich wollte ich mit den mädels zu
sagen 17 getrennt
[Musik]
im mittelpaar missbraucht um das alles
zu verarbeiten
der im bmw und abonnieren
bleib bitte trotzdem
wir sind vielleicht nicht mehr zusammen
aber sein herz gehört nie für immer
[Musik]
natürlich aber ich verspreche euch denn
ich weiss wie gerne in einem bhkw in
challenges jetzt mal spaß beiseite ich
bin nicht mehr in einer beziehung dass
hier kein video oder so also das ist
schon ernst gemeint dinge verändern sich
leute verändert sich das leben verändert
sich und macht euch einfach keine sorgen
um mich okay also ich möchte jetzt nicht
hier und in den kommentaren lesen
so geht's dir gut mir geht es gut alles
super wir sehen uns dann einfach beim
nächsten video und gucken was die
zukunft so bringt klappe wirklich meine
aufnahmeleitung nein zu sagen
hallo
[Musik]
ich entscheide wann und wo mein gott ich
werde überhaupt nicht traurig ich bin
keine toten
[Musik]
wir werden uns dann das nächste mal
wieder und bis dahin haltet eure ohren
streifen und du kannst du ja egal weiß
nicht vier prozent ab